- [Announcer] This is
the green-winged macaw.
Aren't her colors stunning?
So stunning, that the illegal parrot trade
has caused its population
to decrease heavily in recent years.
The green-winged macaw is
considered one of the largest
macaw parrots, but also
one of the most docile.
It is commonly referred
to as the gentle giant.
They are very sweet,
affectionate, and friendly
with both humans and other birds.
Maybe because of these easy-going ways,
these birds have been known
to live upwards of 80 years.
They favor tropical forests
and swamps and savannas.
Their habitat ranges
from Panama in the north,
across South America, down
to Paraguay in the south.
They feed on fruits,
seeds, berries, and nuts.
Their incredibly powerful
beaks are capable
of opening the hardest nuts and seeds.
Along with poaching, their habitat
has been shrinking considerably,
and in certain parts
where they used to be plentiful,
they've become harder and harder to find.
This is the green-winged macaw.